Hey, hello everybody and welcome to
another moneymaking guide. Today I'm
going to show you probably my best to
date. I almost thought about not
actually posting it, but I decided to.
So, what it is going to be is a
money-making method has no requirements
at all. You will need some starting
cash, uh, but it's surprisingly low risk
for being in the wilderness. And I made
over 2 mil in only 15 minutes of running
around. 15 minutes. Um, now I had to
wait two hours for some of the items to
buy. Uh, but beyond that, it only took
me 15 minutes to combine them and then
sell them. They sold within half an
hour. Um, so I hope you enjoy and let's
get started. So, this idea actually came
to me today when I was just uh hanging
out in the sauna. I just kind of thought
all of a sudden that I wanted to get a
maladiction ward or sorry, an odium
ward. And then I kind of realized that
there are pieces to it and the pieces
might be able to be combined and flipped
kind of. Uh, so I kind of had to look
and it looks like you can get between
300 and 500k just by combining one of
these shards into a maladiction or an
odium ward. Um, so what we're going to
do is just buy a couple of each of the
shards and then we're going to run into
the deep wilderness and you can combine
them in this crazy lava forge in the top
right corner of the map. And yeah, so
what we're doing is we're putting in
them for the high price. Like we're not
even waiting for these to buy. We're
just going to put them in. So, as soon
as someone puts one in the market, we'll
buy it up instantly. I can see we
instantly actually bought the Odium
Shard 3, which is the most expensive.
Uh, so we'll put an offer in for the
Shard 2 and the Shard One, and we'll
come back when we have bought a couple
of them. Okay, so we have so far bought
at least one of each piece. So, let's
have a look. Um, actually, perfect. We
got actually exactly one of each piece.
So, we instantly bought one of those.
And, uh, we did manage to get an Odium
Shard 2, uh, which did take the longest,
and Odium shard one, which pretty much
bought right away. And yeah, let's go
ahead and combine them. Okay, so we're
in Edgeville right now. Uh we have each
of the shard pieces, and this is what we
have to do. So, we have to get all the
way up to the very top right corner of
the map. That is where uh the forge is.
It's right above the fountain of rune.
It's quite a long run. Um if you have
desert treasure done, you can teleport
right to the demonic runes. Um but I
don't, so I'm going to take the lever.
And you might think this is kind of
dangerous, but honestly, you protect all
the items. Like, you don't even have to
take anything. I'm picking some food
just in case I get attacked or the chaos
fanatic sometimes messes with you or the
chaos elemental. Sorry. And um yeah,
I'll show you the route. Okay, so we're
just kind of came um down. I almost got
killed by the chaos elemental, but we're
just going right. Um we've just taken
the lever. Keep going right. And here we
are. We're almost at the forge. And once
you get around this little spit here,
you kind of see just going to run right
up there. You can kind of squeeze by.
Um, I think this is the second quickest
way beyond the teleportation that goes
right south of where I am right now. And
yeah, so we're just going to run right
up here. It's actually a very cool
location. I've never been to before or
even really heard of. I don't think
there's any other purpose to this place.
And uh, yeah, all you have to do is use
the ward on the fire. And again, this
you don't require any skills to do this.
Um, all you need is members and just
find a place to use it. It's kind of
annoying. Um, there we go. I've got it
kind of there. Fall back. Bam. There's
an Odium ward. That is just 300k you
just made or about 400k. It depends on
the price. And as you can see, it still
protects. So even if you did die, you
wouldn't actually lose anything. Okay,
so we're back at the Grand Exchange and
we're going to pop it in here for about
uh I think 5050K
and that's a 370
or 390K profit, I think. Uh let's go
ahead and check again. Uh, so we bought
we're selling the ward for 50 50k. We're
going to take off 4.1 mil and then we're
going to take off 500k as well as the
shard leaves us with 390k in profit
which is quite nice. So the rest of the
shards are bought. So we're just going
to do the run again three more times and
we'll come back when they have sold. And
there we are. The odium wards have sold
and that is 1.5 mil in profit right
there. Okay. And while we were doing
this run, my baliction shards actually
bought two. Uh we had an offer in for
all three and um we're on my actual road
to one bill account so we can only
afford one in this account. Um but still
still going to be I think actually more
profit on this one. I calculated it
looks like 474k
and the items actually cheaper but uh
they think they buy a bit less cuz I
bought four in the time that this only
bought one. Mind you only had an
offering for one so it's kind of hard to
know but uh we'll head go ahead and do
this run quickly and uh yeah we'll see
what we get.
So, just to be super clear about how you
do this, I'm just going to go through
the exact way you go. So, you go south
of the edgeful bank to the lever. You
have to make sure you bring a knife with
you. Uh, which is important because you
need to cut the cobwebs up here. I'm
just spam click them down. Um, you'll
notice in a reason why I have the gold
ring with me, but it's not necessary at
all. Uh, so after there, I run down
south past all these hell hounds. And
you want to hug the um the the border
between the wilderness as much as you
can because there is the chaos elemental
which does actually do quite a bit of
damage. So, I'd recommend bringing a
little bit of food just in case. Uh but
again, if you do happen to die, it's not
a big deal because you're only going to
risk uh whatever other things you bring
that aren't the shards because they do
protect over pretty much everything um
that you'd bring anyway. Obviously, if
you brought something really expensive,
it wouldn't protect, but I'm just
wearing black dragon. Really cheap.
Offer some decent defenses. So, again,
just hug this down here. You can see
that chaos elemental is here. Kind of
[__] me up, actually.
Okay, I think we're good. Um but yeah,
so just be mindful of that. And
occasionally, um in this run, I actually
run down south out instead of going back
to the lever just because I didn't want
to run past them again.
Uh but it's kind of up to you. Uh if
you're going to run south and teleport
out, you need to be in 30 wilderness or
below to use the amulet of glory to get
out. And yeah, so we're here again.
We're just going to run up to the forge.
Uh same thing with the maladiction
shard. And I'll show you why I have the
ring here in a minute. It's actually
probably my favorite Easter egg in the
game that I did not even realize existed
until today. Uh you might be able to
guess what it is. So, you're going to
use the gold ring
uh somewhere around here on the flames.
So hard to click on this stupid thing.
Okay, we got it. So, see, and it's
Gollum from Lord of the Rings. And he's
gone. Uh but yeah, so
I love that. So, yeah, just use the um
maladdiction ward on the fire if you can
actually find it. And that's it, guys.
Same process, super easy. Bam. That was
an easy 500k, wasn't it? So, we'll
teleport back and we will sell it. Okay,
guys. So, we are back and the
maladiction ward has sold. It did not
take very long to sell. Probably 10
minutes. And yeah, we So, we'll hold it
for 3.3 mil and we'll take off the cost
of these shards. Uh, all three and we'll
see what we're left with here. Take off
2610 and 476k in profit. No requirements
again, just pure profit. Wasn't that
easy. That is it, guys. I hope you
enjoyed. If you did, please leave the
video a like as well as hit that
subscribe button so I'll be able to keep
in touch with you when the next videos
out. All right, see you guys next